hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am thrilled to be
with some of the cast and the co-creator
showrunner executive producer i don't
know what other titles you have um
director director i'm sorry i should
have said that that's totally on me of
mythic quest
nailed it right uh listen i really want
to say i love your show i want to thank
you so much for coming into our studio
here at comic con um
obviously you guys have wrapped on the
new season and i don't know what how
much you're allowed to say the last
group was very guarded but maybe with
you i thought you were going to say that
they told you everything no they told me
they were very guarded um so they have a
lawyer right off camera uh
yeah right yeah so i am curious though
uh what can you tease about the new
season megan
[Laughter]
i'd like to know what charlotte
remembers
nothing i don't i don't remember
anything i can tell you that it's really
good that's that's true that's not a
secret um no we can talk about things
that were set up last season like iron
and poppy have left mythic quest um
they've gone off to start their own uh
game together um so that's one of the
big uh threads of this season i and
poppy's setting off on their own
of course goes really really well yeah
they just work so well together there
yeah they're off the show by episode two
and uh and also brad has gone to prison
so that's a story line that will be
continuing into the next season um yeah
when we meet him he's getting out of
prison and we'll see what he does with
his life um and uh we also have uh my
character david brittlesby uh
running the well
[Laughter]
i'm left to run the the office and um uh
run it with the you know commanding iron
fist so right i'm sure it's going
probably there very well at the office
what's that i'm sure it's going very
well at the office very well running
smoothly everything's uh yes and uh uh
naomi peregrine who plays carol is uh uh
is slowly making her way up the
corporate ladder there so uh there's a
lot more for this season and she's
hilarious and the um our old testers
rachel and dana
have um gotten together romantically but
split up professionally so uh
rachel's gone off to college and dana is
pursuing her um desires to be a computer
programmer so that's also playing into
this season basically everyone's a part
this season which made it really hard to
film them we had to get really wide
lenses
to keep everybody on camera at the same
time and yeah i'm so curious the ian and
poppy stuff on the show is so good
and i don't know how you guys aren't
laughing on like every take i am
i'm the worst i break every single take
you can usually see if the shots behind
my shoulder you can usually see them
going like this like i know there's a
scene that we did together where you can
see my shoulder you're being really sad
on camera and my shoulders are just
going that was my dramatic moment so it
was kind of humiliating but it was fine
and it wasn't supposed to be funny it
was not what i'm curious about is how
much is every sort of line scripted how
much are you guys in the moment uh you
know coming up with stuff can you sort
of talk about the balance i would say a
lot of it is scripted and we pretty much
always use everything that is scripted
and then
as this as we shoot the scene and it
progresses we'll start throwing things
in and it will evolve and rob obviously
and david too have been doing this for
so long because they're really
old
and uh
and uh so they're like so good at it and
i feel like often i'm just like along
for the ride so rob will throw things at
me and i'll just make a silly face and
people will be like that's funny and
i'll be like no it's not it's just
because i can't think of anything clever
but we have the familiarity of working
on sunny in philadelphia obviously so
there is that that idea of like we have
the script and then on the second third
take is like oh that's funny do that
again and i'm gonna let me respond a lot
of times it'll be just keep rolling
let's let's do that one more time so
there's a lot of like just stopping
throwing something out or megan will
throw something out from behind the
monitor and we'll just add it in on the
on the moment which helps keep it
exciting and fun to discover new stuff
yeah megan always runs in with the best
alts i feel like whenever i see megan
running towards me i'm like awesome
good's coming i'm going to make someone
laugh i have a different feeling about
that
i wrote that response for her so she
made it sound improvised but that was
that's how well we work together i'm i'm
so curious so the night before you're
gonna film a scene how much are you
looking at the script and thinking about
alts the night before how much is it
like that morning and how much is it
really in the in the moment no i do it
right thing to say i know
i am prepared to do that and i always
learn my lines the night before too
yeah um i do not look at the script i
look at the script the day before but
i'm more more like getting my idea
around like what it is we're shooting
the next day but i tend to just do it on
uh once we're there because often with
comedy like
you feel it out while you're actually
rolling and you feel what's feeling
funny and then you want to go towards
that place so you can't really tell that
off the page sometimes um plus i'm very
busy
but i would say too like when we're in
terms of your last question too we'll a
lot of times you you you get the scene
you know you're looking at the scene
that you're about to do and you're
rehearsing before and you're just in a
room with you know the the eps and the
actors and you're like
feels like we should change this a bit
you know so there is some changing there
is some uh once you feel it out like
sometimes you just have to feel out and
be on your feet with with people i have
a question does it ever happen when you
say that where it's like i don't know if
this is working and then there's silence
and you're the only one who feels that
way and you're like oh walk away now oh
yeah absolutely absolutely uh but yeah
you and you have to pitch you have to be
like but what if what if we do this but
bad idea about what happens
some scenes work really great on their
feet and in some scenes you're like this
feels i feel let's just cut this part
and so there's always a little bit on
the fly um but that usually happens in
rehearsal where you refocus on the scene
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of series and
movies so
for fans of the series what do you think
they might be surprised to learn about
what goes on behind the scenes or the
making of the show yeah that's i'm
trying to think of it nothing
maybe you would know i know i'm trying
to think i i mean the first thing that
comes to mind but it does sound a little
saccharine is that all all the
characters on the show are horrible to
each other and then i feel like on set
everyone's out after every tiger i was
like you were so good you were so funny
like i was watching behind the monitors
and you were so good
that's true it's a very different
dynamic to the characters yeah i i mean
we're in a we're in a
horrible muck sweat the entire time i
feel like people don't know how sweaty
david and rob and i are while we're
making the show right i'm just grinding
it out just grinding it out just like
nervous that it's not going to go well
because we put on a nice face for all
these actors you hide it well we know
what we are doing yes i am in total
confidence well i would usually say
maybe in the process too which people
might not know is sometimes we will have
um
the episodes written and then uh we'll
be like what if we what if we don't do
that and we switch it well now we have
to rewrite completely and there's
there's a part in the season that we
normally have where we are completely
rearranging things and then we're
throwing a script out and then all of a
sudden we're behind but it's usually
self-inflicted yeah i remember in season
one rob pitched me what the what was
gonna happen at the end it maybe when we
were shooting the show of the sh of of
season one
and i know what happens at the end of
the show
will you tell me
please you can say no now and then tell
me i want to know what happens at the
end no but talk about season one i don't
care about it what have i told you it's
already happened oh no it's happening
right now
um yeah basically what i was gonna say
is that he he told me what was gonna
happen and i was like oh my god and then
the next day he was like that's not
actually gonna happen anymore it's gonna
be this i was like oh my god and then
the next day he's like it's actually
gonna be different to that so so i just
feel like i'm always on my feet i'm on
my toes sometimes you're trying to land
the plane it's falling apart and and you
just you land it and you stick it just
right but you always think it's just
right yeah
i actually have a question so do you
know how many seasons you want or is it
what's the dream
um
yeah i think we want to no they're only
doing three don't say that we have to do
at least four um no we we want a bunch
um and but we just have a general idea
we've talked about of where we're headed
tell me i can't you know we have a jeep
bench we haven't even told characters
that it feels like we have just an uh
work ensemble that you can keep teaming
up what we like to do is keep
progressing it which i think you'll see
the season as we break off iron and
poppy and we have dana and rachel coming
into their own and splitting we're not
trying to constantly just do the same
pairings and so we're we are trying to
progress it so you can see the journey
from season one to season three and um
so yeah i i think that's
however many seasons
that will allow i think i think we could
keep going as long as we like i mean
sonny's been on the air for about my
entire life
so you never really know yeah um so i am
curious with directing obviously you
i've heard you guys work really fast
which is unusual because every show i
hear about is you know we're hitting the
deadlines but i'm curious how much each
episode are you trying to throw in like
a cool camera shot or how much are you
thinking about you know um that kind of
stuff and how much is it you know what i
mean yeah yeah um on this show a lot
more i would say like on sunny it's like
put cameras on them and let them play
but but on mythicquest we really try to
make things feel cinematic at times we
try to like make it feel a little bit
like premium and elevated so um a lot
like in the quote-unquote normal
episodes
of the show we we try to make them look
dynamic and interesting and this year we
had directing episodes ashley birch and
danny pootie directed one which was
really exciting and they brought like a
lot of really cool ideas to set that was
you know like for interesting shots and
things like that which we cut out of the
final episodes but they were cool to
watch on the day um no but then we do a
standalone episode and i ended up
directing
like part of one of those this year and
that is way more
um you know artistic and kind of like
more cinematic more cinematic yeah then
yeah speaking of the standalone episode
both season one and season two are
exceptional
television like wow um what is there a
pressure in season three to sort of
deliver the goods because the first two
seasons those are
you know next level yes i am currently
feeling that pressure i'm in the edit
right now on our
mega please
this is the sweaty part that i was
talking about earlier um no i'm in the
edit on it and yeah tons of pressure um
and
it's it's inherently a special episode
so you're you're already like okay like
i live up to that time the pressure is
also that because it's not part of the
season arc it stands alone um there's
always a possibility that rob and david
could come back to me and be like yeah
so we're just gonna not air this one um
that's like we could do that and the
season would stand alone um so there was
a little bit of that pressure which is
like oh they could just say no that's
never gonna happen well from what i know
about the stand alone that's never gonna
happen um yeah we'll see those are all
those are always really fun because it's
a way that something like what you can't
do on sunny or a different show is to
break away and do something and tie it
into the season so we always look
forward to it how does it work when at
the beginning of the writer's room
you're stepping in you're thinking about
season three how much is it sort of like
figuring out the end
first and then building towards it like
can you sort of take me through like how
does it all get figured out or is it
episode by episode we generally talk
about the the arcs um like what's what
have we seen from dana and rachel what
have we seen from um well david's gonna
do the same thing let's be honest
no but but yeah what what's the overall
journey we don't always know the exact
destination you know uh we typically
have the the phrase of let's let's just
start in the beginning let's get to the
middle
and then we'll get to the end you know
it's it's but generally we talk about
big arcs what's and sometimes those
start one way but then we we tweak it as
we once you get into the minutia of
actually breaking a story and figuring
out those particular individual stories
it doesn't track to what you plan so you
know um we also did that thing which i
don't know i i have this on every show
that i work on but you end the previous
season and you don't think at all about
the next season and how those storylines
are going to play out you you're not
setting yourself up you're just writing
the coolest ending to that season you
can think of and then you're like that's
next year's problem so we were dealing
with a bit of that when we showed up
this year which is like ooh okay so we
decided to split all of our characters
up right why did we do that again right
we thought it would be cool we sent one
character to jail yeah
great cool yeah but i've spoken to a lot
of directors on movies and they all talk
about the fact that you really can't
think about what's coming next you just
have to do the best job you can with
what you have and then worry about it
later because there's never a guarantee
of another season there's never a
guarantee of another movie you know you
got to leave it on the table we are
guaranteed a fourth season so it's shame
on us uh we we need to know uh no
actually that was one of the luxuries of
having a pickup for third and fourth
season is that we were able to say like
okay we know we're coming back so
where might we then go for fourth season
um well i meant for season two oh for
season two like when you ended season
two like you don't know yeah you know
yeah but yeah but it's great yes yeah
but yeah we wanted to end on a good
feeling in season two which is the
others there's hope and um but uh but
yeah we never you never quite played
that all apart yeah right
yes exactly so we're at comic-con and i
love learning about what people geek out
over i'm not sure if you were able to
walk the convention floor but if you did
what would you be looking at and buying
i did walk the convention floor with
that with that leg uh no it was before
the leg happened got it uh there's a
sprained ankle that's what they're
talking about it's below the table well
i wore silly shoes and i actually i was
going to try to keep it a secret so that
people could think of something cool
that i did oh i was going to say i could
edit out if you don't want to talk about
it please please just i want that i want
it to be a mystery and i want people to
think that maybe i was skydiving we're
going to be editing out the the ankle
talk but i did i did walk the convention
floor and um
uh
the thing that i was most excited about
was the avatar the nickelodeon avatar we
got some pictures with arpa
that was a highlight for me
it's so funny though everyone who grew
up with nickelodeon it's like every
person who comes through is like the
nickelodeon booth it just goes right to
your soul yeah you know
david what are you gonna see
is there a drive to survive uh formula
one booth here that i would i would get
out of that uh
i i don't yeah a lot of my interests
don't necessarily line up with what's
here but i would say that the the
childhood version of me would be looking
for the robotech booth um because i was
very into robotech both toys and the
worlds it there's part of me that was
traumatized by some of the things that
happened it was that the world was
obliterated in that in that show uh and
so i just that that that cartoon sticks
with me and i'm always if i'm in a like
a a toy shop or a you know comic book
store i'm like give me any robo texts
you talking about macro saga what what's
that with robotech i could talk robotech
i'm very sorry i won't geek out over
that go on
i could keep going am i talking about
well you're the the names are gonna
escape me but oh it's like they're with
the original robotech in the 80s there
was like three storylines so it was
macro saga then there was
two others that i'm forgetting yes i
always thought they were like kind of
first generation second generation
generation or something like something
like that yeah and i i do remember there
was a soldier giving a woman flowers and
then just like an atomic bomb blew them
all away and i was like was this a kids
show
we were too young
so yeah that's
that would be my interests
um i'm going to be on a panel with ron
moore
and so i have to um worship him for my
husband's benefit because my husband is
a massive battlestar galactica fan and
he tried to show me battlestar galactica
once and i didn't watch it closely
enough for my husband's liking so i
didn't get to watch the rest of it
because i didn't deserve it um so i'm
excited to meet him uh he was literally
here yesterday really yeah he's a great
guy is he nice he's super nice i'm
excited for that yeah no he's he's great
listen i gotta rap with you guys i'm
just gonna say sincerely cannot wait to
watch the new season and the standalone
episode that i know will be part of it
and i really want to thank you for
coming in and anything i could do on the
site to help promote mythic west happy
to do it
you